welcome to this video playing my Rita
from from Norway d4 not so bad um 64kb
going together Queens gambit chip oh I'm
transposing to the Stonewall Inn quite
questionable line especially but should
be seven less it's very tricky yeah this
is also quite a quite a comfortable
quite a comfortable line for wine let's
see yeah so I get the the bishop
exchanged and an interesting question
now how to how to play here one
important point is that I always have
the possibility to play f3 at one moment
that kicks out is a for night well my
night future night coming to e5 is
impossible to to get rid of it's just
this is journal weakness on only five
okay mmm yeah considering not sure if g3
was necessary yetm know that I think of
it but okay it should be should be an
okay move yeah black can can do that
maybe I'm maybe just here clarifying
things on the on the Kings side I mean
I'm really better developed so any any
opening of the position like taking on
h4 hard f4 should really be a be fine
for me if he goes away takes interesting
yeah I thought that just Tim g2h one
should be quite good so just King here
Andrew page one
you
ok I think I should make sure to get the
knight to e5 it's just better honey five
then on h4 it also keeps an eye on yeah
but this is not it's not that big of a
point anymore the bishop coming down I
have the H file open and so on this is
not a big issue his light squares get
get really weak if he goes for the
exchange and now I even have f3 after
Bishop age five
yeah f3 and possibly c5 can be can be
good c5 from sets up a situation where
yeah if i go here I'm threatening f3 now
to trap the e4 night it's not not very
comfortable okay so this I can take and
here I think it's a good idea to to get
a new Knight to e5 PTSD does not have
Bishop h5 anymore night only to was a
bad piece o Knight f3 to e5 would be
very nice to get in what I need to be a
bit cautious with us the idea to ever
take on any form would be it would be
okay to set up night against bishop but
if I take only for it really opens up
thanks form for black yeah Bishop f5
some of the more than one problem here
which I with blacks position
he does not have any any great rate
squares okay so he jumps back yeah but
it's still still not so easy it is very
nice for height of course but how do you
how do you win this maybe I can play f3
and double on the H file and then maybe
g4 at the right moment like is under
heavy pressure here it's not not much
fun to play this position but but still
yeah I guess this is good why should I
go g4 here immediately and then strike
while I have the chance can come on this
is this is probably the right way to go
not waste much time anymore with with
rook moves or something yeah g5 even
know why not g5 is there anything great
happening after that I but oh wait wait
wait Bishop F Bishop g6 is very strong
here actually yeah he cannot take it
because of mate and this means he has to
has to play some some very unattractive
retreat yeah and now gphi this is strong
okay how to play it most precisely I can
just take it here there's nothing no
here 496 check check winning the Queen
black resigns yeah it's just it's just a
very unattractive position here for
black and I don't know if this this H
for this is only a g5 is great maybe he
should should do something more more
conservative at least here maybe g4 I
don't know I this is very one-sided now
here the position I mean black has
cannot open up further and I just have
this many weaknesses to to use I hear
9065 was even nicer but okay it's just
very one-sided not here f3 is the threat
and now I can yeah 931 is nice it's also
pointed out by the computer nowadays
computer see those things of course so
here it's just an overwhelming position
question is is this F 3g for stuff right
yeah it's in the comp choice IAM for
punishing black directly this is direct
news I wasn't sure I black white can
also do many prep moves like this but I
don't know it felt like I should I
should strike him yeah this is now
totally lost Plus 8 yeah the the real l
root of the of the defeated is this line
this is just bad you should really avoid
the stone wall when white still can play
play the setup and not a defeat Seto
it's a different thing for example if we
look at this yeah if white has played
this
well then f5 is perfectly okay the g3
movers is in of course not bad for white
but committing to the fianchetto is is
much less frightening for black than the
bishop f43 set up here for example um if
we look at this g3 f5 here white goes
with this black and I can always always
take or if Y display an early Bishop f4
you can play Knight h 5mb should be 79
h5 it's the stone wall is perfectly okay
with the night being on f3 and white
committed to the fianchetto but with
whites still being able to play Bishop
f4 III it's really not a good opening
okay thanks for watching